it should be full of love and heart and
applying those skills to food and
gathering around the table my name is
hugh atchison and i'm a chef in athens
georgia at restaurants in atlanta and
athens and i'm gonna make some braised
chicken thighs with red rice i firmly
believe in just getting people to cook
no matter what and my father who has
alzheimer's was born in cuba and born in
havana so this is kind of the dish that
he and i would make and a recipe like
this tells a story and it tells the
story of where my father's from and the
story of how we cook together and just
the story of getting around a table and
nourishing through some thread of family
history we're just gonna cook it on the
other side for one minute so then the
chicken comes out after it's got that
glistening beautiful golden skin and
using all that glorious flavor that's
gathered in the slow cooking of the
chicken thighs which will get scooped up
and scraped up as we add all the rest of
our ingredients making sure to scrape a
little bit aggressively to the bottom of
the pan getting any pain residue from
the chicken because that left a lot of
flavor to enter them into the dish the
alzheimer's association and the new
campaign of around the table is really
just to get people talking about what
dementia and alzheimer's and how it
affects people i mean five million
people are affected or reflected with
alpha farmers in the country and they're
also just an ornamental people who care
for these folks and and love them
inordinately and want to feed them and
sustain them and have them be in a place
of comfort and possibility it's called
around the table and it's a really good
endeavor to get people doing what we
should do whether we're afflicted with
alzheimer's or not which is gathering
around with loved ones and paying
respect for the food that we have and
the company of each other a recipe like
this is really taking the economic
thriftiness of chicken thighs and simple
vegetables and good rice and making them
with technique into something that's
really really powerful and good and
sustaining you know nourishment is such
a beautiful word really good food is
really good for a number of reasons
first and foremost it's about how you're
feeling at that moment in a day and what
you want to achieve with the meal that
you're trying to put together you know
memories of in conversations over food
and over dinner they tend not to happen
over pizza pockets
i think the most important part about
dealing with alzheimer's and dementia
and caring for people in this way is to
make sure that we are caring for them
and giving them an environment in which
they can still achieve happiness and and
find some thread of memory and
commonality and sort of the idea of
pleasure through food but i hope by
sharing my story we all begin to gather
around the table and then talk about
these things and help find an end to
alzheimer's and dementia which is
something i think we're making progress
towards a dish like this just invites us
to gather around the table and it's just
so easy and so
pertinent to how we should be living in
this world and it's
really tasty
[Music]
[Music]
you